how do you spend every dollar to
maximize the thing that you want to
happen the one thing that I can
guarantee connects everyone here is
there's things they'd like to happen in
life attention is the number one asset
it might be a stay-at-home parent and
they want their kid to have a happy life
it's all based on communication the one
thing We're All Tied by here is the
ability to communicate and that becomes
an incredible variable of what happens
all of our political views all of our
biggest standards how we see the world
it's all been story told To Us by
parents by outside forces this is the
thing I've always been fascinated by and
I think the majority of the people in
this room are grossly underestimating
the platforms that dominate the
attention of our society and the
majority of them are sitting on this
thing right
here